[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzar contándoles a lo que sucedió
hace más de 100 años en inglaterra en un
pueblito que pudo haber sido cualquier
parte del mundo en la cual había un
concurso en una fría el ganado
hay una gran exposición y la gente tenía
que adivinar cuánto pesaba ese toro
entonces empezaron a participar anotan
un papel entregan al dueño y hubo un
ganador que fue el que más a salvo al
valor del peso del toro
lo interesante de esto es que un momento
pareció francis galton un pensador de la
época hizo algo bastante sencillo es un
promedio como todos los valores y ese
promedio era muy pero muy muy parecido
al peso real del toro
estamos hablando que el toro pesa mil
199 libras y el poder a 1.197 una
precisión casi que asusta
entonces que lo que quiere decir esto
que ya hace más de 100 años que sabemos
que existe la inteligencia colectiva y
lo que yo me pregunto sabemos cómo hacer
uso de su inteligencia colectiva como
formar parte de ésta porque la capacidad
que tiene un cerebro resuelve problemas
determinada edad algunos acercaban más o
menos otros se alejaban una pareja muy
por arriba como por abajo pero la
capacidad que tiene siquiera un súper
cerebro compuesto por 800 personas que
fueron la que participaron tiene un
potencial capaz de resolver un problema
como éste con gran precisión bastante
interesante y esto es algo que nosotros
nos preguntamos
mi equipo y yo como estudiantes de la
uba diseñadores industriales sa
graduados una carrera la cual nos
encanta solucionar problemas
nos encanta transforma la tecnología el
diseño para solucionar problemas reales
de la sociedad y uno que se nos presentó
este la impresión en braille
y qué problema hay con esto que no hay
contenido
no no es accesible por qué porque la
tecnología que logre imprimir en braille
y que sea accesible
las impresoras reales son muy costosas
esto es un problema para la educación
para la cultura para la comunicación es
tan importante la impresión en braille
para las personas y así como la
inversión en tinta para las personas que
ven entonces acá hicimos muchísimo
tenemos un problema algo que hay que
solucionar y que no se ha sometido
primero bueno mucho ustedes se
investigan son investigadores deben
saber primero analizamos que lo que
existe
nos encontramos en internet había un
montón de vídeos subidos de gente que se
había desarrollado se había dado cuenta
esta problemática y había generado
impresoras braille hechas desde cero
recibirán de impresoras de tinta en
escuelas técnicas en universidades gente
en sus casas que no son académicos mismo
genial
empezamos a analizar todos estos vídeos
y tenemos muchas dudas
empezamos a ver cómo resolvió tal
aspecto como resolvió otras cuestiones
cosas que son este detalle fundamental
es el problema que teníamos es que
cuando le preguntábamos cómo resuelve
tal cosa no respondía
pero por qué por qué tal este video lo
subieron hace mucho tiempo y con una
cuenta que ya no usan o no se acuerdan
que fue hace como cinco años o
directamente no te lo quiere decir que
este proyecto es mío y eso éste que eso
también pasa mucho eso es lo que está
bueno hacer yo me hago cargo de esto
como estudiantes solamente acá también
muchos estudiantes las universidades más
que nada en los que son de rubros de
generación de contenido está uno
plantearse cuánto de todo ese contenido
está realmente disponible la sociedad
cuando todo este contenido no está
perdida en una pc en algún disco rígido
para inspirado en un formato que ya no
es válido que ya no existe y la verdad
que muy poco
entonces lo que nosotros dijimos bueno
acá tenemos una problemática tenemos
este súper cerebro está presente tanto
los actores está ese potencial pero no
se está utilizando
entonces el problema no es de tecnología
el primero el problema en la
transferencia de conocimiento es decir
lo que nosotros propusimos hacer es
bueno primero recambio
el problema no era éste era éste luego
empezar a imaginarnos que lo que se
podría ser positiva anterior
qué es esto un impreso al estilo de
familia usted mismo
qué quiere decir esto una impresora
braille que una persona pueda hacerlo en
su casa en un taller con mínimos
herramentales con mínimos conocimientos
técnicos sino que sea resultado de un
proceso productivo convencional o sea
que no salía de una fábrica y también
qué es lo que queremos hacer es
esencialmente queremos empezar a
trabajar en bloques uno por encima del
otro
es decir no conocimiento dispersado como
ladrillo dispersos y no sino
conocimiento sumado para crear un
proyecto en común no sólo en la
investigación y desarrollo sino también
la producción lo que estamos haciendo
así es esto es ciencia abierta
uu opensource como se conoce en inglés
que para los que no saben nada del tema
le comento que es a lo que ya existe y
se lo voy a aplicar
sintéticamente en dos partes primero
tiene que ver con esto
con el ya mencionado supercerebro con
utilizar este potencial para resolver
problemas para generar un desarrollo y
esto ustedes me dirán bueno pero como se
ve cómo es mi experiencia se ve así como
un montón de gente trabajando en lugano
en samiel lavallol invernal en la plata
de lo que comenzó como un trabajo
práctico académico y terminó sin un
proyecto que si yo tomo vuelo de gente
trabajando complementando conocimiento
alguno se llama electrónica otros además
de programación de diseño empezando a
trabajar colaborativamente en un mismo
proyecto
algunos académicos y otros no y esto
resultados produjo bueno esto una
impresora braille que resulta diez veces
más económica mucho más accesible con la
capacidad de imprimir el código braille
y si ustedes no se desarmaron impresora
de tinta que se ha roto en su casa como
zona centro son muy complejas hay un
millón de piezas es algo que los llevas
al servicio técnico dice no no se puede
para tener que tirar comprar' de otra
porque es complejo y esto como todos
sabemos está pensado para que sea así y
nosotros los diseñadores industriales lo
sabemos mejor que nadie pero acá si
ustedes se fijan gobierno está
sintetizado diseño simplificado al
mínimo para que cualquiera lo puede
entender lo pudo armar ensamblar no
pueda reparar
incluso si se llega a romper alguna
parte y empezamos a usar por una parte
piezas estándar que son presa fácil de
conseguir
son accesibles son económicas en
cualquier parte del mundo se pueden
conseguir los repuestos que después éste
no sabemos dónde buscarlo
por otro lado electrónica arduino que
para los que no conocen es una
metodología electrónico para gente que
no sabe electrónica es decir para
principiantes donde yo compro las
plaquetas las enchufó me dicen que lo
tengo que hacer les bajó el cerebro y ya
está
y lo más interesante es la impresión 3d
como por ejemplo las piezas celestes que
se ve en cualquiera de las bandas a
estas piezas empresa entre ellos son
clave porque hace que uno pueda
descargar un archivo llevarla a la
empresa tres de iguala
tengo una pieza de precisión que es
igual y macao en la que parte del mundo
y ustedes me dirán bueno pero quien
tiene una impresora 3d mera herramienta
accesible bueno la verdad que las
impresoras 3d ya no es algo del futuro
no es algo de lo que vamos a hablar sino
su es una realidad sucede hay muchas
personas con impresoras 3d en todas
partes del país dos partes del mundo y
esto porque a qué se debe
se debe justamente a que también a
impresoras 3d opensource defensa abierta
es un proyecto que ya existe la
impresión 3d en realidad es algo es algo
viejo
por ejemplo si usted ve en estas fotos
la que parece más cara de las dos
realidades una impresora 3d industrial
que salió una fábrica son costosísimas
nadie puede tener una en su casa digamos
ya existen hace un montón pero la que
está al lado por ejemplo ésta se llama
rusa y 3 es un modelo de impresora
opensource que fue diseñada colec
colectivamente colaborativamente
es decir muchas personas que empezaron a
desarrollar a contribuir en un mismo
proyecto a generar un diseño que también
utiliza piezas estándar también utiliza
piezas hechas en 3d y empiezan a generar
un diseño que es fácil ensamblar de
reparar y se empiezan a girar versiones
incluso diferentes versiones de modelos
como éste en realidad y otros no se
puede descargar los planes de internet
el otro eje importante hasta que hable
que hay dos para definir opensource de
nuestra experiencia
el otro que también es muy importante
tiene que ver con la soberanía del
conocimiento
qué quiere decir esto la ciencia se
encuentre liberada descentralizada
porque generalmente si nosotros nos
ponemos a pensar que el conocimiento se
encuentra una entidad a la cual nosotros
tenemos que acceder al permiso y tal vez
podemos acceder a ese conocimiento o tal
vez no
alex es un secreto cambio de esta manera
empezamos a trabajar generando redes
colectivamente en un mismo proyecto no
solamente a nivel mundial sino también a
nivel país a nivel región a nivel ciudad
empezamos a tener una conexión que es
muy interesante porque compartimos la
misma realidad económica social cultural
entonces es interesante pensar en esta
esta marca miento territorial y también
es importante como estudiante
universitario en mi caso de la
universidad pública solamente acá hay
muchos graduados universidad pública
dando cuenta que nosotros tenemos la
responsabilidad no solamente defender la
educación pública que se encuentre
vulnerada sino también de la
responsabilidad de hacernos cargo de que
la ciencia sea de todos y para todos
muchas gracias
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]